we welcome you back to CBS morning it's
time to bring you some of the stories
that we call Talk of the table why
because this is a table and we be
talking and Tony you're in pole position
I got a great talk on the table uh about
an experiment not in a five-day work
week or a four day work week but in a
three day work week this is at a
Chick-fil-A in Florida Miami Florida I
believe and the owner operator the
franchisee has given employees the
option of working a three-day work week
they work 13 to 14 hour shifts Monday
Tuesday Wednesday or Thursday Friday
Saturday and then they're off for four
days uh it's been an experiment since
February at this one location and the
results according to Inc magazine very
good the the manager says 100 retention
they're getting applications in at a
very high rate and people seem to like
it it's voluntary you can work a regular
schedule or you can do this I heard Tony
that they had a one opening and over 400
people applied for this one thing but
how do we feel about working 13 to 14
hours a day knowing you're going to get
four days off I you know that's a hard
job I use work at Wendy's if you're on
your feet for that long carrying box is
working to register it's difficult but
you're able to refresh with the time off
you use that time to visit uh loved ones
and spend time with your kids sleep
sleep yeah yeah like 14 hours I like it
as an option it'd be great if it were
standard everywhere all right so you
guys want to try this during the summer
for CBS boys no put back all the news I
don't mind a four day a week but I don't
know all right